I said that Emmy Noether was the most
important funeral petition of all time
mathematicians you are all sitting in
this room you're all mathematicians and
I don't know if you think of yourself in
that way but I want you to start if you
don't mathematicians you're not just
seeing we do maths you are
mathematicians now when you see a
chapter that says problems I enjoy it
maybe in looking at the recoil really I
want you to change your ways head to
that I heard by the end of this course
which will finish basic reviews of turn
three
you'll look at that and say well of
course that's what's your name a chapter
because here's I'm lucky that the first
thing we should have written underneath
this some it was a little quote for you
mathematicians they are people who find
less easy this is a common misconception
right oh you're really good at
arithmetic or you can see patterns
really easily you can solve Sudoku is
really fast that must like you that
you're the kind of person to be a
mathematician
none of these aren't people who find
math easy I find that really really hard
but what sets mathematicians apart from
everyone else is that they're the people
they're the ones who enjoy how hard it
is okay when you go through to do some
of these problems okay
you must find some really challenging
and the solution will not just slap you
in the face or fix it doesn't make any
sense okay and you might be tempted to
think oh I really do I really don t
really a mathematician the answer is not
ready you find it easy or hard but what
your response to that is okay so we're
going to do one of these problems
together I'll go to walk you through it
I've got to solve it for you and I do
that I'm going to point out three
particular skills put them up here right
now that you will need to demonstrate to
all of the problems that you do
throughout this entire course
the three skills are they sex eliminate
I'm sorry if explore and eliminate and
then communicate okay keeping like maybe
a pen in the big book so that you don't
lose your spot I know what you just
really quickly pick up a little book
this is the the student problem so for
those of you who have never been part of
it initially of course before I want you
to open up the student problems and sort
of even in the middle of the book attic
is quite a struggle you see the first
couple of problems problem one problem
to problem three and over the page it
goes all the way to problem 16 so this
is a 16 week course each week you'll be
required to submit one of these problems
to me and then I like it and I'll hand
it back to you okay now what we do in
the big thick book is either preparing
you to do these problems I cannot show
you how to do these problems this is for
you to submit I'm actually going to take
all of your marks
and then I'm going to submit to the
Sharia mathematics trust and you get a
certificate you know credit distinction
high distinction all that kind of thing
so I cannot help you with these
questions nor can you help each other
with actually writing these questions in
your answers however you're welcome to
discuss it with like oh how did you a
person is your life and things so long
as you actually form your own solution
so the question of about to demonstrate
for you out of the problems I enjoy it
aimed at preparing you to solve problems
one and form to write
so these skills here one two and three
are there going to be what you're going
to need the problems one and two and
really all of the problems that's why
was done alright so now I joined you by
Justin of our yoga community the
question I'm going to ask us putting
together these questions fall under
problems I enjoy question for it's such
an archetypal
profession about the ages of three
children so I'm going to give you
a couple of visits to breed this
question to yourself to think about it
and to figure out how you would start it
all right are you puzzled are you
puzzled now one of the reasons why this
is called problems I enjoy is because
each of these problems the wonderful
thing about it and I hope that gives you
you sort of an attitude check out of it
is that certain problems certain
problems if they are posed well if
they're clever then they can reveal to
us sort of gaps in our own understanding
it's a little bit like a magician if you
don't ever watch the magician before
like a real yeah okay if you watch the
magician before we don't really go to
magicians to be tricked because who
enjoys that right and we know obviously
there's some trick behind it what we go
to a registered to do is to help us
understand all right
let's challenge our assumptions about
how we know or how we think we do things
right I was sure that object was going
to end up over here but somehow she made
it appear over here right at this
problem sort of does that to you because
you look through you're like okay I'm
following so far I'm following and then
you're like violent what defile is that
do anything so let me explain first
clues or first suggestion is we're going
to dissect this question dissection is
something that's important whatever
question that you do but these problems
are particularly sort of in boiling them
because you have all this information
here you and you just look at it all at
one go it's just overwhelming okay so a
classic mathematical strategy is to
dissect and sort of work at it in pieces
okay now hopefully you can see there are
three distinct pieces that you can
dissect this question into three to six
sets of information as admittances and
exactly that's okay they are going to
help us solve this so I'm going to say
when I think this question four is it
cool so maybe you want to follow with
the angio running in your book okay
there are three sections of information
I'm just going to put a B MC okay what's
the first equation that you can see
which is depicted hangs on story what
you tell me
okay mystery children
but immediately after knowing this three
children they tell you the first act
that actually helps you work out
something about three children what do
you know about their ages what's the
very first thing there are two 13 okay
here's the first piece of information
but we already know doesn't take us much
imagination to realize I telephone
enough I need more information and
that's why there are more sections more
pieces that we didn't assess we'll come
back this add to 13 in a bit what's the
next thing we should get all okay so the
three ages they multiply to there in
addition to say it's not a studied or
the reason why they say study or is
actually I think they end assistance by
saying it's not just there it's
something they can supposed to write so
the three ages multiplied to a known
number in other words this person who's
finding out he's trying to work out the
agents right knows what that number is
though is the product of these three
numbers okay do they do it here to you
at this point the question no what's the
last thing you do my own twist okay
let's just write that down my room okay
so this is the 30 that we've done and
questions in you know all of that better
can you have a look out for particularly
like normal students methods
one of the things I've seen a bit
exception one and two is you look at a
problem you're like oh my goodness we
are not paragraph of text there or
there's just so many simple that I'm
even able to start the which side is you
dissect it into digestible pieces okay
we've just done that in what we had to
start with but there we've got parts
that we can sort of work out gently
which leads to an XP we're going to
explore these options and then we're
going to try and eliminate our
possibilities okay
so let's explore three children their
ages add to 13 13
13 is not a very large number right this
is actually within the realm of
possibility for us to actually explore
by hand now some things are not
some things are clearly designed when
you look at it you know one of the
questions that you often get is
something like and how many numbers less
than a million are divisible by seven or
something like that okay you're like
okay they clearly don't want me to lose
out a million numbers okay but here when
you see 13 you okay I have a [ __ ] do
this so I'm going to pause your movement
I'm gonna ask you to see how many
combinations do you think there are you
are having for your work with a friend
to do this of ages of three children's
that add to 13 it's a small number it
might be quicker than you think to you
here we go